vsauce kevin here and i'm about to bust
the greatest female tycoon of the 19th
century using forensic math i just need
skim milk and amputated leg and a family
of nerds to do it
millions of dollars were at stake and it
all came down to handwriting
[Music]
i've told some stories about how math
has perverted the pursuit of justice and
destroyed lives but when one of
america's richest women tried to steal
even more money
math detected her fraud teddy green was
bred to make money and she was the best
at it at six years old hedy was reading
financial newspapers to her father who
owned a whaling firm in massachusetts
she tracked stock prices with her
grandfather and by age 13 was the family
bookkeeper in the 1850s the family had
millions which in today's money is tens
of millions but hedy needed more and
when her aunt died she saw dollar signs
first you need to understand hedy her
life was all about money and she racked
up a fortune that would be valued well
into the billions today
she was known as the witch of wall
street but she was famously miserly she
was just as obsessed with making money
as she was with never spending any of it
here are some examples she spent so long
trying to find a free clinic to treat
her son's leg injury that she waited too
long and it had to be amputated she
refused to use hot water because fuel to
heat it felt like a waste of money she
wore one black dress and a single set of
underwear that she only changed when
they wore out when she bailed out the
new york city government by writing a
check to cover its budgetary shortfalls
she was living in boarding houses
because she wanted to she said just
because i dress plainly and do not spend
a fortune on my gowns they say i am
cranky or insane teddy green wasn't
insane but she was
a criminal and that's where the math
comes in when her aunt sylvia died in
1865 her will stipulated that about 1
million dollars would go to charities
that's about 15 million today
the other 1 million would be put in a
trust for hedy so half for charity half
for hedy here's what happened next hedy
remarkably produced an earlier copy of
the will stating that 100 of her aunt's
fortune would go directly to her which
seemed pretty convenient it also had a
page attached that invalidated any
future wills which seemed really
convenient the estate's executor thomas
mandel saw it and was like i don't think
so so what did hedy do she sued the
estate and that's when nerds came to the
rescue
charles sanders pierce was a literal
genius by age 23 he had three degrees
from harvard he eventually became one of
america's greatest logicians including
realizing in 1886 that electrical
circuits could carry out logical
operations
that resulted in the digital computer
decades later but in 1865 he entered a
courtroom in boston to analyze aunt
sylvia's handwriting charles compared 42
samples of sylvia's signature and
concluded that it had 30 down strokes in
graphonomics a ballistic stroke that
conveys a distinct change in the
absolute velocity of the pen my
signature has 18 8 and kevin 10 in
lieber here's a question how consistent
is a signature how much did sylvia's
vary from sample to sample how much does
mine vary let's find out right after
this this video is sponsored by morning
brew when you finish doom scrolling
after you first wake up get informed and
entertained with the morning brew free
daily newsletter get up to date on tech
finance and business in just five
minutes in this one i found out
comedians are trying to get paid
royalties for their jokes like musicians
are for their music learned australia is
the drunkest country and tech shares
like twitter and robin hood took a hit
traditional news is dense and stiff but
morning brew is witty relevant and
informative it really is the easiest way
to quickly stay up to date on everything
that's going on every single day so if
you're interested in business tech or
finance click the link below to
subscribe to morning brew for free and
thanks again to them for supporting
vsauce2 okay i signed my name and then i
made 42 more signatures and tried to
make them match then i judged each
sample against the original signature to
find out how many of the 18 downstrokes
in my name were the same i looked at the
size length and angle to determine
whether each stroke was substantially
similar they followed a normal
distribution and the result was an
average of
7.405 matches out of a possible 18 so
only 41 percent the same and i was
really trying to make them the same
sylvia's 42 signatures were probably
done over a period of years but the
interesting thing is the variance my
signatures have a standard deviation of
1.326
which means that 99.73
of my signatures should fall between
3.427
and
11.383 that's a range of plus and minus
3 sigma the z score of each sample
indicates how many standard deviations
that sample is from the mean basically
how much of an outlier it is my most
deviant sample was 10 matches for a
z-score of 1.957
i actually did one more set of
comparisons just to make sure i compared
signature 21 to all the others the mean
was
6.810 matches and the standard deviation
was 1.418
the highest z score was still only 2.249
based on my 42 samples how deviant would
a perfect 18 for 18 match actually be it
would have a z score of 7.989
nearly eight standard deviations from
the mean the odds of a signature being
seven standard deviations from the mean
are about one in
390 billion the odds of 7.989
figure it out and tell me in the
comments back to hedy
charles pierce found that sylvia's 42
samples had an average of six downward
strokes matching the will's signature so
about 20
and conform to a binomial distribution
just like mine and probably yours when
charles compared the signature on the
first page of the will to the signature
on the attached second page he found
that all
30 downstrokes were a perfect match a
100
perfect match his father benjamin pierce
was a harvard mathematician he testified
that the probability of sylvia's second
signature being a perfect 30 for 30
match was 2.666
times 10 raised to the power of 21 or 1
in two sextillion
666 quintillion so
yeah benjamin pierce said such
evanescent shadows of probability cannot
belong to actual life which is an
amazing quote uh yeah hedy traced and
sylvia's signature she lost the case and
fled with her husband to london when the
family threatened to have her indicted
for fraud but she didn't really lose
after five years in court she was
awarded six hundred thousand dollars
from the estate less than the original
legitimate will gave her but still 12
million dollars in today's money and the
state never brought criminal charges
against the wealthiest woman living in
it the following year hedy had a
daughter who she named
sylvia
teddy green died during a heated
argument with her maid about the
benefits of skim milk today her estate
would be valued at 5 billion
she really was america's first female
business tycoon and she wasn't all bad
she became an anonymous philanthropist
and served as a nurse to care for
friends and family in 1951
sylvia green died leaving over 99
of the family fortune to charity i've
made videos about the crazy odds of two
people having the same name and having
weirdly similar fingerprints and having
rare tragedies strike twice in the same
family i've shown that math alone is a
terrible basis for convicting someone of
a crime and insane odds can still mean
innocence with sylvia and howland's will
we have to consider the totality of the
circumstances hedy's motive her
obsessive greed her miraculous
production of a will that just happened
to be entirely in her favor
all combined with truly astronomical
signature odds knowing when not to
believe in coincidences is just as
crucial as accepting them one in a
billion okay if one in a billion people
won a lottery that means about eight
people alive right now would hit the
jackpot it's not impossible a mountain
of evidence plus one in 2.6 sextillion
yeah i don't think so eddie teddy green
spent a lifetime accumulating money
power and influence and she could never
get enough of any of it but in the end
all of hedy's precious millions couldn't
compete with the pierce family's
sextillions
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you